il n'a jamais fait le coup de point dans
la cour de l'école mais il pratique la
politique comme un sport de combat au
point d'avoir déclenché un des incidents
de séances les plus marquants du début
de
[Musique]
législature bonjour Aurélien saintthoule
bonjour Alors on a tous étudié les Fabes
de la Fontaine quand on était à l'école
ou au collège mais il n'y a un agrégé de
lettre classique pour transformer une
fable en arme politique on va revoir
votre prise de parole qui était donc au
nom de la France insoumisse pendant le
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat ce
jour-là vous avez pris pour cible le
rassemblement
national bien sûr on connaît la
stratégie de l'extrême droite qui agit
comme la chauve-souris de la fable dans
le parti des oiseaux elle montre ses
ailes dans le parti des fachotx elle
montre son poil et elle inint un
rat vous ne connaissez pas la fontaine
peut-être si si si vous ne connaissez
pas la fontaine non mais monsieur onut
non s'il vous
plaît non je pense que vous vous
comportez comme des adistes et vous
risquez de dégrader le Mobilier national
non s'il vous plaît je ne vous ai pas
insulté je vous ai caractérisé alors on
voit que que votre prise de parole a a
vraiment mis en colère vos collègues du
rassemblement national euh il faut dire
que c'est assez étonnant vous avez un
ton calme des mots posés donc on
s'attend pas à ce que vous portiez des
des oup aussi aussi rude que
cela c'est ça fait partie de vous vous
aimez provoquer vos adversaires c'est
non je enfin moi je me suis jamais
considéré comme un provocateur en
revanche là en l'occurrence je trouvais
que c'était c'était exact c'était précis
l'extrême droite et faschisante parti
des fchau
zadistes puis assimiler le le RN au au
parti des rats c'est quand même
extrêmement violent parfois on peut se
demander si vous êtes pas au bord de de
la ligne rouge de franchir la ligne
rouge non je crois que en l'occurrence
le sujet ce jour-là c'était l'hypocrisie
du rassemblement national qui d'un côté
parle de lutter contre l'islamisme et
cetera et puis moi j'avais suivi dans le
débat présidentiel j'avais suivi en
particulier les questions sur la défense
nationale et j'avais lu le le programme
de Marine Le Pen sur la défense
nationale et il était question de
renforcer les alliances avec l'Arabie
Saoudite le catar les Émirats arabes
unis et donc c'était cette hypocrisie
que je voulais pointer je trouvais que
c'était amusant et puis c une référence
que j'avais à l'esprit et qui m'est
venue simplement mais je me j'ai pas du
j'imaginais pas du tout que ça
provoquerait cette réaction en tout cas
quand on quand on vous entend comme ça
citer la fontaine les mots sont une arme
en politique bien sûr on est dans un
débat public qui est souvent un peu
corseté
euh où on a on cherche à se faire
entendre donc si on peut piquer
l'intérêt soit par la curiosité le bon
mot dans le débat public en France en
particulier euh on a un peu peur de on
se cache un peu derrière son petit doigt
on a un peu peur des mots en
l'occurrence dire l'extrême droite sont
des fachot le mot est un peu familier si
vous voulez mais il est rigoureux il est
juste du point de vue analytique si vous
me permettez le un mot un peu pompeux on
va remonter un peu le le fil de votre
votre histoire vous expliquez que au
collège vous étiez un peu le le souffre
douleur des autres le bon élève chahuté
par le reste de la classe sauf que à 13
ans même si on mit bien les mots comme
vous bah ça suffit pas pour se pour se
défendre est-ce que c'est une période
qui a laissé des traces en vous
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a laissé des
traces je crois que ce qui reste en moi
c'est une forme de de compréhension et
de bienveillance je suis pas du parti
des winers voilà je crois que ça c'est
le c'est quelque chose qui est très loin
de moi j'ai j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
grandir de pouvoir être un adulte qui
fait face et cetera et ça c'est une
bonne chose en revanche je suis très
sceptique devant les gens qui croient
que il y a des Winners des gagnants des
perdants des riens euh tout ça me met ça
me met même pas mal à l'aise en réalité
je désapprouve totalement et c'est loin
de ma culture vous avez eu un par un
parcours scolaire brillant lauréa du
concours général en version latine une
classe prépa au lycée Louis lerand à
Paris vous êtes donc agrégé de lettre
classique euh tout ça pourrait donner le
sentiment que vous êtes issu d'un d'un
milieu assez favorisé ce qui n'est pas
le cas au contraire euh vous dites j'ai
la conscience de classe j'ai vécu des
moments de honte social est-ce que c'est
là qu'il faut chercher un peu les les
racines de votre engagement politique en
grande partie oui c'est clair que moi
j'ai grandi dans un milieu disons
populaire pour faire un peu vite euh que
j'ai été confronté à l'inégalité à la
difficulté sociale une des premières
choses que j'ai dites à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon quand je l'ai rencontré
j'étais tout jeune militant je disais
écoute Jean-Luc tu sais les gens se
rendent pas compte que quand on est
pauvre et ben on a une charge mentale
qui est beaucoup plus importante on se
baisse systématiquement pour acheter le
le prix le moins cher on calcule tout le
temps dès qu'on a une petite tuile bah
tout tout part à Volot bon ce genre
d'expérience je l'ai vécu dans la dans
ma jeunesse dans mon enfance j'ai vu ce
que c'était donc j'ai été assez
conscient des inégalités et puis il y a
quelque chose qui est important aussi
c'est que en grandissant je me suis
rendu compte que ceux qui dirigeaient le
plus souvent bah il n'étaient pas les
meilleurs et ça c'était assez frappant
pour moi vos parents n'ont jamais été
encartés dans un parti ou membres d'un
syndicat or ils ont aujourd'hui un fils
qui est député et puis un autre qui est
responsable syndical chez Force Ouvrière
on vous voit ensemble avec votre frère
Mathieu saintoule comment vous expliquez
ça
c'est ah je sais pas alors il faudrait
dem y a quand même un terro quelque part
oui oui bah il y a un terro d'éducation
je pense queon a une ucation qui nous
rend disponible et
surtout à l'engagement et puis on se
sent concerné on pense que on a une
certaine responsabilité à ne pas laisser
le le monde tourner à l'envers comme il
tourne à l'envers vous dites de votre
frère lui c'est l'ouvrier moi c'est
l'intello ça peut donner l'impression
pour vous ce sont vous êtes de deux
mondes séparés qui presque non on n'est
pas deux mondes séparé mais on est très
complémentaire ce serait hypocrite de
dire que on a le même parcours qu'on a
le même vie la même vie et cetera euh on
est très proche et euh au contraire je
crois qu'on s'est on s'enrichit
mutuellement énormément on garde euh
voilà moi je j'ai un parcours académique
mon frère non euh mais je lui ai d'une
certaine façon donné un point de vue sur
ce monde-là et de la même façon que lui
il a une il est en prise beaucoup plus
directe avec le monde du travail je vais
pas le cacher et que moi il m'a appris
énormément de choses vous avez commencé
à militer au Parti de Gauche de Jean-Luc
mélenchan en 2009 avec votre frère
justement euh vous faites partie un peu
de cette nouvelle génération de députés
de la France insoumise qui est apparu en
2022 à l'Assemblée on va voir une photo
je vous ai associé à cinq autres députés
de la France insoumise vous avez sans
doute une petite idée pourquoi on voit
sur sur la photo Damien maudé Arnaud
legal David guirud Clémence guetté et
Anne stambbac ternoir alors on a tous
travaillé soit pour des députés soit
pour des groupes des élus voilà vous
avez tous été collaborateurs
parlementaires soit à l'Assemblée soit
au Parlement européen soit au groupe de
la France insoumise euh moi ça me
surprend un petit peu parce que LFI est
un peu souvent présenté comme le parti
antiystème et là ça donne l'impression
que finalement LFI bah mise sur des pas
des professionnels de la politique mais
quand même des gens pas loin d'être des
professionnels de la politique est-ce
que c'est pas un peu contradictoire je
crois que le paradoxe c'est en fait il
faut prendre le sujet dans l'autre sens
je connais pas le détail de la vie de
mes collègues mais et camarades mais
pour ce qui me concerne en tout cas je
suis devenu assistant parlementaire
parce que j'étais militant et pas
l'inverse je suis pas j'ai pas rejoint
un parti politique parce qu'il m'a donné
à manger c'est pas pour faire carrière
c'était pas pour faire carrière on va
s'attarder sur ce qui est sans doute
l'épisode le plus marquant de votre
début de mandat c'était pendant le débat
sur la réforme des retraites ce jour-là
vous êtes adressé à Olivier du sopt pour
dénoncer l'augmentation du nombre de
morts au
travail vous ne pouvez pas arriver ici
et me dire que la suppression des CHSCT
n'a eu aucun effet ce sont 150 orphelins
veuf veuve en plus et vous avez la
responsabilité chix vous êtes un
imposteur et un
assassin j'ai eu il y a quelques
instants à ce micro des mots que
l'émotion et l'emportement mont fait mal
choisir et qui sont
déplacés je souhaite évidemment les
retirer et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre et je me tiens à
sa disposition pour avoir un échange
plus personnel et lui présenter à
nouveau mes excuses alors vous qui
maniez la langue française avec
subtilité on l'a vu au début de
l'émission vous qui aimez bien voilà la
finesse de de cette langue française là
vous qualifier un ministre d'assensin
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah je crois
que les images sont assez claires on
voit que je suis très en colère parce
que dans la séquence qui précède
j'évoque au sujet de la réforme des
retraites le fait que le risque
d'accident mortel au travail augmente
mais de façon très explicite avec l'âge
des salariés et donc je lui demande
qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu pour les
personnes qui vont rester au travail qui
donc vont risquer de mourir et je lui
dis que c'est d'autant plus grave que
ils ont avec le gouvernement précédent
supprimé les CHSCT donc les comités
hygiène et sécurité au travail et donc
que le le nombre des accidents mortels
au travail a déjà augmenté que donc il
peut pas balayer ça d'un rever de la
main et c'est précisément ce qu'il fait
il me dit que mes chiffres sont faux que
je m je suis et le mot assassin donc il
sort comme ça vous l'aviez pas préparé
ah non non il est pas du tout préparé la
seule ce que j'ai la main en réalité
c'est une petite fiche sur laquelle il y
a les chiffres exacts du nombre de morts
année après année au travail en fait le
mot assassin était impropre parce que
évidemment le ministre du travail n'est
pas responsable directement de la mort
des gens mais par contre il y a quelque
chose qui est important et qui est bien
connu dans le débat public c'est quelle
est la la la part de de responsabilité
des politiques est-ce qu'on est respons
on peut être responsable mais pas
coupable donc dans le cas de de de de
Monsieur dusopt évidemment il est pas
coupable et il ne sera pas coupable de
la mort directement des personnes par
contre il est clair que quand on a des
responsabilités il il faut être capable
de les regarder en face si des gens
meurent au travail du fait de décisions
politiques qui ont été prises il faut
être capable de le voir qu'est-ce qui
vous a qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à
présenter vos excuses comme vous l'avez
fait la séance a donc été interrompue
vous êtes revenu à la reprise pour
présenter vos excuses on d'abord je
voulais pas que le débat s'éternise sur
sur cet aspect et puis à titre personnel
moi j'aime avoir des mots les plus
exactes possibles donc assassin c'était
pas le mot le plus exact donc voilà
après comment vous expliquez que soit
très rare de voir des hommes politiques
s'excuser parce que s'excuser c'est si
si la bonne foi caractériser le débat
public je pense que on nésiterait moins
à s'excuser le problème si vous voulez
c'est que est-ce que c'est pas aussi une
question d'ego non honnêtement je crois
pas qu'on soit tous bourrés d'un ego
démesuré je crois que dans le débat
public ce qui est aussi intéressant
c'est de voir que après ses excuses le
ministre lui dit que il n'accepte pas
mes excuses estce qu'on ne verra pas non
plus plus c'est la façon dont il est
sorti de l'hémicycle juste avant en
proférant des injures à mon égard mais
c'est pas grave
je si on avait eu juste un échange de
personne à personne il a pas eu cet
échange vous l'invitiez à voir cet
échange il a jamais eu lie mais bon
écoutez-mi c'est pas grave je j'ai
pas personne n'a envie d'être ami avec
l'un ou l'autre c'est pas le sujet mais
pourquoi on s'excuse pas bah parce que
d'une certaine façon le risque qu'en
face on abuse de votre excuse est est
très important on va passer à notre à
présent vous allez devoir compléter les
les phrases que je vais vous proposer si
cyil Hanouna m'invite dans
TPMP ah bah dis ça parce que vous êtes
un peu en guerre contre Boloré vous êtes
d'un commission d'enquête je suis pas en
guerre du tout mais
par dans TPMP non j'iraai pas en
revanche peut-être que il viendra devant
ma commission d'enquête ah vous espérez
c'est en réflectionion dans le cas de
cil Hanouna ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il est la personne ou en tout cas son
ses programmes sont ceux qui ont fait le
plus
le plus souvent
l'objet de de sanction ou de rappel à
l'ordre de l'arcom donc moi je travaille
sur ce sujet de la façon dont les
chaînes respectent ou pas leurs
obligations et en particulier qu'elles
sont contrôlé par l'arcom je suis quand
même curieux de savoir ce que Cyril
Hanouna a pu répondre à l'arcom quand on
lui a dit écoutez là vous avez abusé et
cetera donc peut-être qu'on
l'auditionnera quand je sens monter la
colère pendant un débat à l'Assemblée ah
quand
je l'expérience si vous voulez de
l'assassin me fait dire que oui j'ai
appris à respirer un peu et aller boire
frais mais je crois que aussi cette
colère elle est est légitime elle est
partagée par aussi énormément de nos
concitoyens donc elle doit pas faire
dépasser les bornes mais elle doit
pouvoir aussi s'exprimer enfin comme
disait plin le jeune je teste votre
maîtrise en ce qui reste de le jeun je
vais pas avoir la du latiniste que vous
êtes je vais pas avoir de de citations
spécifique de plin le jeun c'est un peu
c'est un peu spécifique je j'aime bien
si on doit avoir une citation latine
j'aime bien celle de Terence euh je suis
humain et rien de ce qui est humain de M
étranger je pense que c'est quelque
chose c'est une bonne base pour fonder
l'universalisme politique que je défends
et ben ce sera le moi de la fin Merci à
VOUS Aurélien saintou d'êre la politique
et moi
[Musique]
merci